[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to a very
special edition of ask Evan here with
Maria today we're going to answer a
question from one of our readers anele
anele says dear Evan I regularly get
your newsletter and enjoy the great
content can you give a demo of how you
do the mail merge to send out
newsletters please
unfortunately Evan has switched from
Outlook to Gmail therefore I will be
doing the demo with you today
however to make things a little bit more
interesting instead of doing a
newsletter we're going to do a mail
merge for my website party so what
you'll need is a word document an Excel
document and obviously I'll look to send
your mail merge so the first thing I'm
going to do is show you my invitation
which is my word document and I'm going
to read it for you and show you where
we're gonna place the placeholders which
is going to be found in our Excel
document sorry about that
so it says dear and isblank so we're
going to place the first placeholder
here you are cordially invited to
Maria's website party once you arrive at
the party you will receive receive a
nametag which will indicate your website
so here's going to be the second place
holder once you receive your nametag
please be seated in section blank so
here we're going to place the third
place holder if you have any questions
please feel free to contact me I'm
looking forward to seeing you soon
Cheers Maria so what I'm going to do now
is show you my excel document which has
our four placeholders I know in the word
document I only said there was three but
you always need to add an extra
placeholder which is going to be the
email address which you're sending to
the recipients receiving your mail merge
so the first placeholder is going to be
my guest
then it's the second one is website and
the third is the section where my guests
are going to be seated so once you have
your Excel document ready you're going
to save it to a place where you're not
going to forget you're going to need
this right away so you're going to save
it and close it if you don't close it
it's not going to work properly then
we're going to go to our word document
and we're going to open tools and go to
mail merge manager I know for some of
you that have windows instead of Mac it
may look a little bit different but if
you follow the steps you will have a
successful mail merge I promise so the
first step we're gonna do is um click
create new and since I already clicked
on this before I'm gonna click on form
letters
step two is you're going to get at your
list and the list is your Excel list so
you're going to open data source and go
to party invitation that's the name of
my Excel document and click OK here it's
going to ask you which sheet you want to
use because you can have multiple sheets
in Excel document choose the correct
sheet and you want the entire worksheet
cell range you're going to click OK and
then we're going to go to step three
where the four placeholders are shown so
now what I'm going to do is make sure my
spacing is correct because once you send
a mail merge to I don't know 50-100 a
thousand people you want it to look
really nice so I'm going to make sure my
spacing as well and I'm going to add in
the guest information here we're going
to add in the website information here
and lastly there's seed section also
just a quick note here when you're
making your Excel document make sure you
give each section of your placeholders a
precise name for example I could have
named guest whatever but it would have
been harder for me to know which
placeholder to place where depending on
how many placeholders you're going to be
using when you send your mail merge so
one time put in my three placeholders
I'm going to go to step four
and also remember we're going to ignore
step a placeholder number four which is
the email address so number four use you
have a filter option here it's let's say
you have a party in your you invited 50
people and you're only sure above 40 the
other ten you can click options and make
sure that you keep them out of the mail
merge the next option is the preview
results this is my favorite if you click
on the ABC button or view merge data you
can actually see all your placeholders
so it doesn't just show the title it
shows the actual information and then
you can go through each of your
recipients and make sure that the
spacing is correct name is spell correct
the correct website
well if you're happy with that you're
going to go to the last step and
complete merge so you're going to click
on the button that says generate email
messages and here is where we're going
to place our fourth and very last
placeholder email because you want it to
email them you're going to put a subject
my website ready and here you have an
option to send as text attachment or
HTML message I usually prefer to send it
as an HTML message because I have
pictures and banners in my signature and
I want people to see it but if you don't
prefer the pictures to be shown you can
always send it as a text so I'm going to
choose HTML message here and then you're
going to click on mail merge to outbox
so pretend you clicked on that if you go
to your outbox and click on your send
items you will see your list is slowly
starting to build up and all the
recipients on your list will be
receiving the email so once you're
finished you can close this and your
recipients will have their email and I
hope you guys enjoyed the video and I
hope it was very simple if you have any
questions please please please feel free
to comment below and I will respond to
you as soon as I can thanks guys
[Music]
you